hello everyone hi welcome to screen
junkies central we are broadcasting live
from San Diego during comic-con hey
how's your comic-con going having fun I
love this I'm Alicia Malone I'm here
with the wonderful Andy signor I'm here
with the lovely Alicia Malone how fun it
has been that movie fight with Devon was
fantastic that's insane if you're
watching now you can go back and watch
the movie fight right now we've got a
really exciting panel for you we're
talking about comic book adaptations how
they go from the page to the screen and
also you can watch this live right now
on Facebook on YouTube also on sj+ we've
got a bunch of other shows coming up for
you tomorrow and the rest of today so go
to screen junkies dot-com slash central
to get all your information and before
we get into it Andy I just want to give
a big shout out to thank all our Plus
members because it's because of them
that would be here without them yes
amazing event so if you want to enjoin
and enjoy nearly 20 weekly original
shows and hours of live content join
right now at screen junkies calm slash
plus and use the offer code esterday
central 16 you'll get 50% off the annual
membership that's huge that's a really
good deal and if you yeah it's like two
bucks a few couple bucks a month so much
cheaper you're not gonna get any cheaper
please please please check it out yes I
love it but let's get into it we have
some really exciting guests for you so
from Lucifer we have these show runners
Joe Henderson and LD Mudd robux come on
out hey guys
Hey Joe how are you doing hey how you
doing come on in pick a chair grab a mic
how are you guys feeling how's Comic Con
Bay's for you we just took the train in
so we've been here for about an hour so
it's awesome
so you're fresh we got you fresh yeah
well at least
I know the pilot episode premiered at
last year's Comic Con so what what has
this last year been like for you this
ride oh my god last year when we were
here we hadn't even aired yet so this
year it's gonna be completely that a lot
of people are dressed like Mays
especially men yeah I I've been here
many many years that last year was the
first year as a professional so to be
able to sit on this side of it when
normally I'm sitting out there was
incredible and now it's just even more
exciting because last year no one had
really seen the pilot now people have
seen the show people seem to dig it so
now it's just fun to meet the people who
like it it's it's exciting it's awesome
it's really exciting and I know the show
has just been renewed for season two
second graduation I had a question just
because I want I want to get a little
technical with you guys and have the art
because we have a lot of aspiring people
out there technical I know with this
answer and I know how complicated this
job is but like what does the showrunner
do we really just sit around delegate
and you delegate the weirdest weird
answer that question is it depends on
every show because it depends on how
much you want to do like you can really
get lost in the minutiae of the show in
really wonderful ways or you can hire
the people and delegate and trust them
and check in and there is no right
answer like sometimes it's great to have
people underneath you that can do
certain things and sometimes there's the
brilliant show runners who dig into all
the details I think like the first thing
you're in charge of is just the scripts
so you know you have your team of
writers you have a staff and you just
you you just move the train forward
while you're and then it's really hard
when you get into production because
you're in editing while you're trying to
break a story while you're trying to get
that outline out and that script out so
you're sort of like spinning plates yeah
it's just it's juggling chainsaws and
and children and seventeen other things
at once but it's exciting and it's
thrilling because you start at 9:00 a.m.
with a with a meeting about props and
then attend 10:00 a.m. it's a meeting
about the story of
that it's gonna shoot in three weeks and
then you go into post and then you say
hi to the writers room and they wonder
what on earth you're thinking and then
you go talk to them really quick and
then you go into post and look at a shot
it's it's just relentless and awesome
it's really tiring but it's it crazy cuz
it's I just what I I'm sure it's an
insanely tough job but it's like I think
people don't understand like they hire
directors and writers to do episodes and
they move on but you guys really have to
contain the whole thing and like be the
creative overseers and making sure
that's working it's kind of like it's
especially if you have a v8 do you like
I do
it's very hard to concentrate on a
million you just really do have to
constantly like you're casting you're
looking at wardrobe like the silliest
things happen you're like I don't I
don't like the bangs a lot a lot of
bangs calls the nobody in particularly
the the big thing I think we're very
happy with is we love people we trust on
the show and we have a lot we have a
wonderful writers room and things like
that and that's your first move is you
hire really good people to do their jobs
and you're always involved in every
aspect of it but you are trusting them
because they are damn good at what they
do and that includes we also use having
a wonderful cast we we're very fortunate
with the talent that we're working with
well Lucifer is such an interesting one
to talk about when you're talking about
taking a comic book from the page to the
screen because it is based on a
character in Sandman but would you say
it is a police procedural drama more
than anything it is the devil solving
crimes yeah it is a police procedural on
police procedural mythological
serialized comedy drama Horror Show
Wow everything favorite part of that you
know that's what I love about it is
every half-hour it's a different thing I
love that I can sit down at a keyboard
and write uh literally in the second
episode of season one a guy getting
kicked in the balls in slo-mo like
that's that's a moment that happens in
our show and then you have a tragic
moment in your episode then one after
which is this moment between our two
characters having this sort of
connection because our hero has cut off
his own wings and he has these scars on
the back so like we have
jokes and then we have just genuine
emotion and B to be able to run that
gamut I think is amazing yeah I mean -
and and then you also get to have
everything heightened because it's the
devil and and God and every I mean so
everything has immediately super high
stakes yeah you don't have to but then
at the same time you you can ground
everything because it's just a father
and a son and two brothers and so it's
relatable so I feel like you know we get
to have everything in a way like we get
to we get to explore this mythological
world but still keep it completely
relatable to people and to us I mean
we're always like oh we're stupid we're
like the biggest fans of our show we get
it we get to tell a story about the
ultimate family yes that's cool
we're the dad's God you know yeah
exactly
so I what I love and I'm sure everyone
at comic-con is super excited about this
but you've got a very special person
just being cast as the mother please
tell me who that is and about her Tricia
Helfer
not only I mean she's so good in
everything she's done previously but
like she's lovely oh my god why are the
same kitten rescue group she does she's
such a nice person
she's very sensual and day one she
showed up playing the character and it
was just you knew you just like oh yeah
that's that's who we've been imagining
and we didn't even know we were
imagining that like just fantastic I
think everyone's gonna be thrilled with
me when they say she had like such a
tall order of just a very strange kind
of character to play and not just if on
paper you go oh she's the devil's mom
okay well maybe she's you know this arch
kind of Cruella De Ville sort of thing
or something no spoiler well I was gonna
say are there any big changes in season
two that you can help set us up for I
mean that's that's the big one
that's the big conflict to me season one
was all about dad it was father issues
and the sense of living up to it / going
off on your own path a lot of daddy
issues going on yeah yeah it's if only I
was channel
something but what season two is all
about mom and it's all about it's funny
because dad's this distant figure that
he never hears back from and here's mom
here on earth
what do I do with that what does that
mean it's just that's gonna drive
everything in a really nice way yeah
he's he's been you know felt rejected
for I think his whole life and now and
there's a whole backstory which we will
not tell between him and his mom but you
know what is it like when you start to
actually get maybe parental attention or
love is it good is it bad is it you know
how does that feel so that's what we'll
be exploring it's so interesting the way
this is inspired by a comic book but not
a direct adaptation of it how much
freedom do you get to sort of do your
own thing with it make your own
characters hugely it's so different that
that weirdly sets us free yeah it's I
mean the way that we've approached it is
very much the character templates are
the same but I mean where we our show
exists in Los Angeles it's not in the
wonderfully insane world that Neil
Gaiman created and it might carry shapes
like it's our it's Los Angeles it's
grounded but at the same time Lucifer is
very similar to that character he is
that that mischievous figure maze is
still the loyal soldier amenadiel is
still fighting him but even that
character has changed quite a bit like
it's what we try to do is use the the
character dynamics as a starting point
but filter it through our very different
world I think the hardest thing about
doing it adaptation is when you do have
to stick to it and and especially you
know you have a loyal fan base I mean
the good thing about about the two comic
books that we kind of we kind of live in
between them
Sandman created Lucifer and then at the
end of Sandman you know he leaves hell
and then so much happens in Lucifer
that's so big and we knew that if if we
put that on TV it would I don't know
it's it's just it's it's more it's
almost better in your imagination than
it would be you know to actually see a
play out so this is just kind of right
in between when he has this bar in Los
Angeles and we just exploit like making
that a giant shop
of our own kind of and costing is such a
big thing when it comes to a show like
this
Tom Lauren such a charismatic cast that
you have what is the fan reaction being
like to them because people have really
taken to these actors they hate Tom but
I mean Tom Tom Ellis is just he he gives
the devil a soul to me like he makes him
he gives him hard he gives him a
vulnerability he gives them a sense of
both danger and weakness all at once
it's an amazing thing and then Lauren
balances him so well and it gives and
gives in those moments of vulnerability
and has those moments of her own that
lets this improbable concept feel very
real yeah I think both of them as people
I mean you should see them off-camera I
mean they are they are x-rated for one
thing no but they they have so much fun
as as people and I think I think that
comes across on screen I mean the thing
about the character of Lucifer is that
he has he's kind of a teenage boy kind
of a forever teenager and he had to have
this just this joy to him I think a Glee
to being sinful and that's just like its
its inherent and inherent in who Tom is
and that comes through and Lauren is
like she just meets him like just I mean
they she will slay him actually like she
she just gets way Roger than he does
well we actually have a clip to show
from Lucifer so let's roll it and turn
around awkwardly and stare at the script
smoking here oh dear what will be kind
of now my melons please officer she's
gonna rescue mm-hmm I think I might know
your mother what's your name
Lucifer exactly
my name's Beatrice but I really because
new Trixie that's a hookers name what
the hugger
ask your mother so why I'm from Chuck
over there she was blowing me she
created a fake snapchat account nice
take from me so I keep learning a new
touch touch swear oh it's so cold she is
she is the cutest thing he's so cute
where did you find her gosh cast casting
yes the usual way Alicia thank you she's
amazing that's incredible well we're
talking all about comic book to screen
so we actually have another special
guest to bring out and join you guys
Andy do you want to do the intro yes
this guy actually written a bunch of
movies you might have heard of Thor
x-men first class and he wrote the
episode of the flash that our mr. Kevin
Smith it was a series here great
episodes acts tense come on friend of
the show thank you for coming Zak I
thought that meant I'll be sharing a
stage with the Prince of Darkness and
the Lord of lies very nice we are like
like two perfectly nice human beings
isn't that the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled so exact something
interesting that I found so you your
next project Booster Gold that was
actually kind of sort of announced on
movie fights with Kevin Smith according
to a lot of different news sources it's
sort of kind of was it can be traced to
me
but you know I mean I mean you know
Kevin is a very you know persuasive
interrogator and and you know he knew
what it was even though he didn't
actually say what it was and then and
then the morning that we did movie
fights a big interview with Greg
Berlanti came out where he spilled that
that I was gonna write Booster Gold with
him directing and and it's like okay
cats out of the bag we can say it now
connecting the dots so you're and you're
now doing some stuff for the flash -
you've been wrote an episode are you
writing anymore yes I am I just finished
my first episode of the third season
which is gonna be episode 5 season 3 is
looking really good people and I'm
probably gonna be doing maybe two or
three more over the course of the season
they basically have me like under the
flash roof to do a few episodes and then
and then because I'm doing Booster Gold
for Greg he's under the same roof and
it's all we're all one big happy
superhero family well I'm curious cuz I
asked them how the showrunner works but
like how did it so it as a writer for
hire to come to a show like what's that
like who do you have to report to and I
does that work the chain of command is
really interesting it's like you know
Greg up at the top and then you have
like two super show runners you've got
like Andrew Kreisberg on Supergirl and
flash and you've got Marc Guggenheim on
legends of tomorrow and an arrow and
then you've got people whole multiverse
and then you've got show runners you
you've got show runners who are just in
charge of one show each and then you've
got me who's you know basically the guy
who comes in two days a week and eats
all the food out of the refrigerator and
it says what if we did this so it's like
the best job ever for Joey how do you go
about finding writers like Zach to come
in and do different episodes because I
imagine it must be like a jigsaw puzzle
they have to fit in with the entire
overarching you know whatever storyline
and then also bring their own style well
we're very fortunate in season two that
we've actually kept almost the entirety
of our writing staff and so we
what we just did is we read samples that
in our case had a sense of humor that's
what we're looking for we needed to know
whether or not you could not only tell a
joke but understand the emotion behind a
joke
and so just read through a whole lot of
scripts it's kind of like almost casting
a show or something or writing a pilot
like you you're assembling a dynamic you
know you don't want everybody to have
the same skill you want somebody who's
louder in the room and somebody who's
more contemplative and then it says like
some one genius thing you know like I'm
sure it's it is interesting well I don't
know about that but but you're
absolutely right in that in that it's
not widely known that writers rooms
chemistry is as important as on a cast
like if you have someone who just comes
in and is relentlessly negative every
day and like never pitches anything but
just shoots down other people's things
like that's that's I've known people
like that that's poison for a room any
any aspiring writers if you get the
opportunity the worst thing you can ever
do is be the know in the room it's the
easiest thing to do because everyone
sees the problem everyone knows act five
makes no sense at all the question is
instead of just saying this doesn't make
any sense and going for the easy win do
you have the constructive fix those are
the people that are invaluable and but
like that's the thing is you got that
one person it can bring down a whole
room although you also do want the
person or people that make sure that
you're not in that kind of bubble where
you all convince yourself that something
is good and sometimes you need someone
who's a little bit of a reality check on
that one one show I was on we had this
one staff writer and the showrunner
nicknamed him the scowler monkey because
he would he would sit he would sit in a
room and he wouldn't shoot down things
but like he'd start he'd look at the
board kind of like this and like that
and the showrunner would see and it's
like scowler monkey you've got a problem
with this don't you and invariably he
would diagnose something that the rest
of us had missed and and you know it's
but he also he would offer the diagnosis
and the prescription not just not just
that this is effed up
and I don't have a fix it's gonna say if
somebody made faces it may I just throw
grapes at them and then I would eat them
yeah like I imagine that because we've
had we've been lucky enough to we did a
show very smaller scale than yours but
when you're in that razor I'm trying to
crack that like what's the trick
sometimes how do you get yourself to
solve the problem because I you're
building these universes and this world
and you have to tell a story that's
several episodes long and it's tough on
these shows and especially Network I
feel like cable and some of these things
are getting a better advantage because
they get less less episodes like what do
you feel about that I mean what I feel
like it's it's kind of our job as
showrunners to create the kind of
atmosphere that says relaxed and
nurturing as possible I mean I've been
in rooms where you're kind of terrified
and and that's just not the kind of
place that's really gonna make creative
things happen I mean we do a lot of
drinking absolutely true and eating and
no but we take walks we watch stupid
things if we're stopped if we're
stock.we I mean which is very do you
ever like admit I'm not saying you've
done it but have you ever been you're
like this one's kind of filler does that
ever happen I feel like I do that an
honest trailer sometimes like if we were
writing those I'm like this one's not
our best one ask us around episodes in
the back half like that right now right
now we're feeling awesome I mean the
challenge of 22 is is that stretch
between 13 and 18 or so the hammock
episodes yeah exactly it's it's it's
keeping the it's keeping the show from
losing from from losing its tension and
losing its shape and in those parts but
to what you were saying I think the
other the other thing is you know there
there's the relentless schedule but you
also have to have the patience to go
through the 10 ideas that are almost
right and wait for that one that hits
the tuning fork in everyone's brain and
it's like yes that's the right one
that's the actual solve instead of that
good enough and they need to shoot
something tomorrow solve like here's an
example like we had an episode that we
wrote out to story area which is like
our three-page like hey here's here's
the kind of story we were thinking and
Warner Brothers they liked it but they
had some thoughts and we just blew it up
and just completely rethought it
you know it's like we're like we saw we
could understand the note behind the
note which is this really isn't landing
and then as we dug into what wasn't
working for them we realized that that
actually opened up story that all of a
sudden gave us an episode that we
absolutely loved and that's not to say
that we didn't we really liked that last
that previous version but sometimes you
need to step back look at it and go oh
no wait this could be cool times you are
wrong well like that's a good lesson and
you're probably quite close to it as
well exactly
yeah but Zach I remember seeing a great
tweet from you when you wrote flash and
it said you're directed by Kevin Smith
how exciting is that when you're writing
an episode and you get paired with a
director that you really admire I mean
all of the direct you know the the the
flash and the Berlanti people are really
good at picking directors but I have to
confess I mean Kevin Smith is one of the
reasons why I wanted to do one not only
why I wanted to do this but why I
thought that me without a film school
education someone who was just a fan and
who studied things intensively might
actually be able to do that I mean he
was the guy who was living the dream and
you know like I I read the books about
how he made it in things like that so
like literally 20 years later you know
the 20-year overnight success
you know actually getting to actually
getting to write something that he
directed was just it was a dream come
true and then for him to turn out to be
a just a delightful and lovely human
being aside from being that talented was
just you know that was like a bonus also
great episode thank you well for you
guys now you've got season two coming up
I imagine as showrunners you you really
focus on getting a great first season
that wraps and then you get renewed
which is great but at the same time
you're like oh okay we've got to really
bring it and top ourselves from last
season and on that note I'm curious like
do you save things like if we get season
three this would be really great when do
you let go or yeah on particularly not
great ideas for like season five
five yeah it's actually the opposite
like we're trying to we're we're season
two is just as important as season one
season one is when you you know get your
legs season two is where you take off
running like most of my shows the the
love of the most season two is where you
see all the parts start to click
together like we know what our cast can
do we know what our writers can do we
know what we can produce in a way that
sells the show like what's so exciting
is we feel like we're cooking with gas
and so we season three us may hate
season two us because like what what
else are we gonna write about but right
now we're just going if I can compliment
you for a second - I was when when that
project was announced
I mean I'm someone who loved the Lucifer
character going all the way back to you
know not the New Testament but his
appearance in the Sandman
fantasy you know going all the way back
there and when I you know and like I was
the typical like they took one of the
great vertigo characters and turned it
into a police procedural and then I
actually watched it and it was like this
is like the best possible version and
and and they got the the core of the
character they got the core of the
character and it's like yeah there are
the procedural elements that you need to
do on the network show that to service
but it's like I think you guys are the
Good Wife of Fox supernatural procedural
can that be the headline to everything
we got away for Zach to write a comic
episode oh yeah the fringe of brilliant
evil come talk
making it happen you know Lucifer has
been great at creating its own thing the
comic book fans can be tough they if you
get something wrong though from movie
sites it can be rough if you get a
detail wrong zach is there a lot of
pressure with with the fans or you find
that they are very supportive of
everything the direction that you go you
can't think about it I mean the fans
have been super supportive I've also you
know it's it's been interesting i-i've
I've now adapted adapted superhero
material in several different camps with
several different styles there was the
Fox camp with the Fox Marvel characters
there was the you know being there for
phase one of Marvel when they were still
trying to figure everything out but had
the Marvel House style and now there's
the you know I'm I've got one foot in
the DC Berlanti verse and then I'm also
bringing the kind of spirit of the
Berlanti verse into the DC movie
universe and it's it's each one of those
has a different thing but at least what
I've tried to do in all of those is is
honor the spirit is how to put this not
be embarrassed by the material that I'm
adapting and that's that's I think that
that's what's deadly and that's that's
where they go wrong is is where they're
you know where they're running away from
the elements of it it's like you know
the flash is not afraid to have a shark
man wearing pants super-intelligent
talking gorillas you know it's like it's
it's comic book TV we're not ashamed of
it we're embracing that but we're also
you know I hate the word grounded
because every executive uses it you want
to beat them over the head because it's
such a cliche but you ground the
emotional reality of it at the same time
as the characters are in a fantastical
world they're having real human
reactions to them I would say anything
you want to tease about season 3 yeah
are you allowed you know the there is
the Berlanti CW satellite is orbiting
right now in
got a particle beam trained on me and uh
yeah there there is gonna be awesome
there there is gonna be an awesome
Berlanti verse crossover that's gonna
incorporate everything and we've got
cool we've we've got I know it's been
announced already we got Draco Malfoy -
the tom felton added to the cast and saw
the first day of dailies he's freaking
awesome he's so good and we let him use
his real accent which is a key if
possible and for all of you people
casting out there if you cast an English
person let them use their real accent
yes they're not all Hugh Laurie he was
English because he does such a perfect
American accent but when they aside from
Hugh Laurie or Meryl Streep when they do
accents it's like a Mac running PC
software you can do it but you're like
only 75% is fast so you're not getting
all of their performance if they have to
spend you know use half of their brain
thinking about you know don't talk like
this
I can't a horrible cockney action I just
wanted to ask you a quick question Zac
before we wrap you know you say
everything you've done it's it's
incredible what is it like for you with
comic-con do you find yourself embraced
by fans is this your jam to come here I
love it even though I have crowd
anxieties so I I can only take I can
only take so much
I you know like screen junkies has been
a godsend because they have a very nice
quiet room with Hamas and back so
conditioning so if things get
overwhelming I go back sit quietly eat
hummus and and that helps me but this is
the first comic-con I've ever been to
that people have actually recognized me
and I think it's from being on the
screen junkies show so I love it I'm a
kid in a candy store it's great being
here and it's great being I haven't seen
any booster gold's yet though I want it
my goal is
my goal is like 2018-2019 people who
love the Booster Gold movie so much that
there will be like wall-to-wall blue and
gold you know in eighteen central we're
great we're gonna do a Booster Gold
contest with you thank you guys so much
with you yet though because we've got
something coming up later on they're
gonna be on our screen junkies pal room
sixty e at a screen Jackie San Diego
comic-con official so I'm excited
he's fighting max landis that's gonna be
crazy all you Gen Xers I'm gonna be
holding up the Gen X honor against that
millennial punk I love max but I'm gonna
show no mercy
Zac sense LD Maduro Joe Henderson
thank you and thank you for everyone for
tuning in so much more coming up for you
on SJ central so keep watching bye bye I
just did the house thanks again to
sponsor t-mobile with double the LTE
coverage get your screen junkies fix and
more places to watch our previous show
click to the left